[Music]
actually I brought up the Oscars there
is an award show that is more
prestigious than the Oscars that's right
I'm talking about last week's golden
collar Awards okay the golden collar
awards are new they honor outstanding
performances by dogs in film and
television all right now in the film
category Martin Scorsese was very upset
that Blacky the dog from Hugo was
initially passed over for a golden
collar nomination okay and so he asked
for this had a big online campaign well
that is nothing compared to this
injustice in the television category
they snubbed our old friend triumph the
insult comic dog yeah yeah thanks that's
great mock outrage terrific now
fortunately triumph didn't let this snub
stop him from crashing the red carpet at
this year's golden collar Awards this is
just a few days ago he brought on a
camera crew here is his report here at
the Hyatt Century Plaza all the
glitterati of Hollywood is tearing a new
hole into the waste of time continuum
yes it's the golden color award every
celebrity you could possibly not care
about is here on the red carpet a
veritable who's available in Hollywood
is this [ __ ] nominated
hold on she's had some work done like 16
nipples down there yeah I have her
before picture yeah did a great job I
have to say oh yes yes
look at that I've already been on that
red carpet
hey nominated dog wag your tail if
you're a son I knew it
[Applause]
okay so now I wasn't nominated and I'm
back from the red carpet they will
regret this
no justice no poop no justice no food
two four six eight I am going to
defecate I am going to defecate I got
more I will not forget your snub I will
not forget your snow on my penis I would
round it sounds a little stop coming
from you more of a god one so triumph I
know she got our snubbed this year what
are you doing here it's a disgrace you
know what really gets me that Wilfred
guy gets nominated for dressing up like
one of Marv Alberts fantasies what are
they gonna do next
nominate the puppet wasn't that your
plan I'm not the puppet man soccer if I
want to pop it if I want to pop it would
I be anatomically correct no I would
check it out
I deserved we're not just for the Conan
O'Donnell show I was also in the Tree of
Life and that really yes nobody saw
that's all
nobody saw what was right there with
Brad Pitt oh yes did you meet what even
you go black a black you yes closeted
homosexual yeah we should say Blacky
likes to take it to the back you know
what I'm missing out on take a look at
this gift bag look what these dogs are
getting tonight reach down deep first
this kills me and Michael Vick we never
forget never forget who is this this
lamb chop lamb chop and she plays you
Colt on Suburgatory Suburgatory of
course no offense you know but I have
very sensitive hearing and even I have
never heard of Suburgatory does she ever
sniff under your ponytail hoping it
smells like
just for me very nice
smells like secretary he dogs from the
Real Housewives
yes gigolo who's a sex monster you know
cheers $50,000 on Twitter yes he looks
thrilled dogs yeah are you sure he looks
like his mom was gangbanged by Sammy
Watts yes look at him he's beside
himself with joy between the crappie
award and getting to hear a cardboard
tuxedo the golden collar goes Brigitte
Estella and Modern Family
congratulations are you excited yes
we're very excited
tell me Richie that's some sick form of
domination come back here tell me what's
it like to work with Sofia Vergara and
those two doggy bed she stuffs in her
blouse
Brigitte hey hey that was a joke on
Sophia's food
you know what I'm ugly turned on by
oh that's a good view oh yeah
[Applause]
all right just stay right there stay
right then down just a little bit just
bend down a little bit you're seriously
leaving me high and dry [ __ ] he
triumphs signing off same Conan I stand
corrected the golden color awards are a
great great program for me to be
[Applause]